michelle does this mean that the hotels
are better
the hotels the hospitals i beg your
pardon are better prepared
uh this time round many of them have
already seen a sort of second wave but
of course that could
get even worse over the winter
very much so i mean hospitals certainly
that we've spoken to
in europe over the last couple of weeks
have said in terms of ppe
and equipment they're definitely better
prepared but the sheer number of people
now being admitted to hospital
and to icu units is putting
huge pressure uh on the system the world
health organization said last week that
europe had hit
a new high some 700 000 cases and europe
now accounts for a third of cases
uh globally so we're seeing different
measures in different countries
um this week to try and stem the spread
of the virus and try and stop more and
more people being admitted to
hospital in belgium where i am the
health minister
has warned or warned in an interview
over the weekend that
we are as he put it we are approaching a
tsunami
um and there are brussels the capital
and the
wallonia region are particularly hard
hit so this evening
we'll see a curfew coming into place
between midnight and 5am
bars restaurants and cafes are now
forced to close for the next
month social contact outside of the home
limited to just one person
for the next month we've also heard a
warning today from
uh poland's health minister saying that
cases there
could reach as many as 20 000
a day from next week and they've they've
announced that the main football stadium
in warsaw
is going to be turned into a field
hospital they've also ordered cities
right across the country to create new
hospitals simply
uh to cope with covid we're also seeing
today in
italy a rule of six being introduced a
maximum of six people
uh allowed to meet at bars and
restaurants there will be table service
from
um six o'clock in the evening now
they've stopped short of a
full lockdown but mayors in different
regions will be allowed to
implement the shutting down or curfews
in particular areas from nine o'clock if
they deem it to be necessary
michelle thank you